lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
practiquemos la creación de expresiones
con exponentes usando problemas reales
veamos estos problemas el área de la
superficie de un cubo es igual a la suma
de las áreas de sus seis lados vamos a
dibujar el cubo
más o menos así y tiene seis lados
traslados que vemos aquí y tres que no
se ven si este cubo fuera transparente
se verían esos otros tres lados así de
manera que tendríamos seis lados
y nos dicen que esteban tiene dos
bloques cúbicos que quiere pintar uno de
los cubos tiene lados que miden cuatro
unidades
imaginemos que este cubo que dibujé es
el que tiene cuatro unidades cuatro
unidades en todas sus dimensiones y el
otro cubo tiene lados que miden dos
puntos cinco unidades vamos a dibujar
este otro cubo que es más pequeño
así
más o menos
y tienen de lado 2.5
escribe una expresión numérica con
exponentes para el área total de la
superficie que tiene que pintar vemos
que tenemos seis lados aquí cuál es el
área de cada uno de estos lados bueno
hay seis lados como este así que seis
lados que tienen esta área y el área de
este lado mide cuatro por cuatro o
cuatro al cuadrado así que el área de
este cubo será de seis por cuatro al
cuadrado
nuevamente el área de uno de los lados
es cuatro al cuadrado y tenemos seis de
ellas
aplicamos la misma lógica a este otro
cubo el área de cada uno de los lados es
de 2.5 por 2.5 que podemos escribir como
2.5 al cuadrado y tenemos 6 lados en el
cubo que es de 6 x 2.5 al cuadrado ya
tenemos la expresión numérica con
exponentes que nos piden esta es el área
de la superficie del cubo amarillo y
esta es la del cubo azul con esto
terminamos solo recordemos la anotación
en este punto no indica un decimal está
más arriba e indica la multiplicación y
no verán cada vez más conforme vean
álgebra también pude haberlo escrito así
6 entre paréntesis 4 al cuadrado más
entre paréntesis 2.5 al cuadrado y aquí
cuando escribimos el número junto al
paréntesis va a multiplicar lo que sea
que esté dentro del paréntesis así que
aquí también tenemos 6 por 4 al cuadrado
igual que acá así que mientras
construimos estas expresiones también es
bueno familiarizarnos con esta anotación
hagamos otros dos problemas
la con chinchilla es un pueblo que se
estableció en una parte remota del mundo
en 2010 su población se ha triplicado
cada año desde que se fundó si había mil
cincuenta vamos a escribirlo mil
cincuenta personas cuando se fundó cuál
será su población después de seis años
recuerden que se triplica cada año
entonces para el primer año vamos a
multiplicar esto por tres el segundo año
lo multiplicamos por tres el tercer año
el cuarto año el quinto año y el sexto
año hay otra manera de escribir esto de
manera más compacta la población inicial
del pueblo mil cincuenta por tres a la
seis a la sexta potencia ya que tenemos
63 que se multiplican entre sí o como lo
mencionamos 1.050 que es la población
inicial por entre paréntesis tres a la
sexta el objetivo aquí no es evaluar
esto sino construir estas expresiones
para saber que podemos evaluar esto y
encontrar la respuesta correcta todo lo
que nos piden es escribe una expresión
numérica con exponentes es lo que nos
piden que describa la población después
de seis años que es lo que acabamos de
hacer vamos a resolver otro problema
un muro cuadrado con lados de cuatro
metros de longitud vamos a dibujar este
muro cuadrado aquí está
y tiene tres ventanas cuadradas vamos a
dibujarlas en otro color entonces aquí
están mis tres ventanas los lados de
cada una de las ventanas tienen 1.5
metros de longitud
lohan adquiere tapizar el mundo por lo
que necesita determinar el área del muro
que no incluya las ventanas escriba una
expresión numérica con exponentes que
describa el área del muro en metros
cuadrados que lo haga tiene que está
pisar bueno cuál será esta área va a ser
el área del muro menos el área de las
ventanas
cuál será este pues 4x4 que es 4 al
cuadrado y la gente llama esto al
cuadrado porque es así como se calcula
el área de un cuadrado y ahora tenemos
que restar el área de estas tres
ventanas menos 3 y en cada una tiene un
área de 1.5 al cuadrado esta es una
ventana con área de 1.5 x 1.5 está
también y esta otra también esta es el
área que le ganaba a tapizar